ci hanno in questi periodi ossessionato
con il problema delle fake news è il
problema della società contemporanea al
punto che è stata eletta parola
dell'anno dall'oxford dictionary per il
2016 e diciamo che in qualche modo la
definizione sta per acquisire i fatti
non per via razionale ma per una
tendenza all'emotività dell'essere umano
lo scopriamo nel 2016 l'essere umano non
è razionale nel 2016 come se lo fossimo
mai stati torquemada tante altre storie
insomma insegnano come l'essere umano è
ben lontano dall'essere razionale
illudersi che l'essere umano sia
razionale è una famosa per esempio è
spesso e volentieri la scienza e quando
non capisce le cose
la scienza evolve per falsificabilità un
processo di conoscenza che evolve nel
tempo e per errore si pone laddove non
conosce come un approccio che viene
chiamato ermeneutico per farla
perdonatemi il termine con le
supercazzole ovvero noi ci mettiamo lì
sopra e cerchiamo di riempire un gap
informativo con cose che non sappiamo e
creiamo nelle storie molto molto
scrittura creativa e quello che abbiamo
provato a fare noi invece è uscire da
questa prassi e cercare di sfruttare le
migliaia le tonnellate di dati che
lasciamo ogni giorno online ad esempio
abbiamo idea di quanti i tweet circolino
in ogni secondo quanti post vengono
fatti su facebook ad ogni minuto
siamo nell'ordine dei milioni una
quantità impressionanti un bacino
impressionante di informazioni che
possono essere utilizzati da noi
scienziati per capire cose di come
funziona la società ben al di là della
speculazione e ovviamente l'approccio
mette insieme sociologia psicologia
sociale semiotica ma non con un
approccio basato sulla intuizione bensì
sull'approccio empirico ovvero
utilizziamo il metodo delle scienze dure
la fisica cerchiamo di fare la fisica
dei sistemi sociale partiamo da mark
zuckerberg che nel 2007
parlando di facebook ci dice che non
vuole creare una nuova comunità ma buoni
soltanto permettere alle informazioni di
circolare più velocemente
beh è un passaggio importante in qualche
modo sta dicendo che lui sta
distruggendo il sistema informativo in
quanto tale toglie di mezzo la
mediazione prima eravamo abituati agli
esperti che selezionavano per noi le
informazioni la testata giornalistica
la redazione seleziona va ai post e le
informazioni ad esso un gattino o una
rivoluzione un colpo di stato sui social
seguono gli stessi processi di selezione
egli ci abbiamo un problema il nostro
cervello che è lo stesso che fa scienza
evolve per apprendimento per
approssimazioni e siamo macchine
programmate per risparmiare energia ad
esempio questa frase di albert einstein
il problema delle citazioni su internet
è che spesso sono false quanti di voi si
sono accorti che non e einstein ma
quelle bruno lauzi
questo per dare un esempio di come
funziona il cervello umano e cervello
umano ma per approssimazione capelli
bianchi baffi bianchi
la frase ci potrebbe stare perché
einstein appartiene ad una delle persone
che in qualche modo ispira il nostro
modo di pensare e quindi va bene
passiamo avanti passiamo oltre
e questo passare oltre ha creato dei
problemi non banali
ad esempio eravamo nel luglio del 2015
alla quantico university viene fatta una
conferenza stampa in cui viene detto che
sarebbe stato fatto da chi ha poco
un'esercitazione antiterrorismo sono
solo del texas
la conferenza stampa a parte c'è il live
tweeting giornalisti che twittano
nell'arco di poche ore a quelle
esercitazione militare l'annuncio
dell'esercitazione militare diventa la
prova che
obama sta per fare un colpo di stato sul
suolo degli stati uniti e ovviamente noi
siamo portati a pensare che a ma quanto
sono imbecilli quelli che ci sono
cascati c'è cascato il governatore del
texas che ha allertato la guardia
nazionale dicendo di presidiare i
confini oppure quest'altra e il senatore
ci renga il senatore ci tenga
non esiste è una pagina facebook di cui
si ha un senatore come nome e ci renga
come cognome è una bufala inventata da
un cappellaio di firenze questa bufala
fatto 35.000 condivisioni nella prima
settimana e dice che questo fantomatico
senatore ha fatto una proposta per
finanziare i parlamentari in caso di non
rielezione con 134 miliardi di euro
altro esempio di come funziona il
cervello umano 134 miliardi di euro
cifra troppo grossa
non riesco ad immaginarla comunque sia è
plausibile si inserisce in un contesto
di sfiducia rispetto al governo e alle
istituzioni passa e diventa virale
quest'altra pertini che dice quando il
governo non faccio che il popolo vuole
va cacciato quelle masse con le pietre
non importa che la fondazione pertini
labia smentita tantissime volte
e ancora argomento di dibattito
all'interno della politica perché
incentiva il simbolo incentiva ad
esprimere la sfiducia nei confronti
dell'istituzione
qual è il mostro che è qui dietro
l'assassino mostro si chiama
confirmation byas pregiudizio di
conferma è quello che ci porta a dire
che gli altri sono idioti per affermare
la nostra intelligenza e soprattutto per
il meccanismo che ci porta ad acquisire
le informazioni perché sono coerenti con
la nostra visione del mondo ea rinnegare
quelli che sono a contrasto se sono
nella juventus
prenderò tutte le informazioni a
supporto della bellezza e della forza
della squadra il mio eroe
tutte le informazioni a contrasto sono
un giornalista sono convinto che le
fiction siano un problema
non importa che è stato dimostrato
scientificamente che portare le fonti
e cercare di fare giornalismo non
risolve assolutamente il problema
continuerò a credere che col fact
checking posso risolvere il problema
delle fer news
il problema è mostruoso tanto che dal
2013 è nominato tra le minacce globali
nel global risk report del world
economic forum insieme al terrorismo
perché perché un'informazione passa
senza filtri emerge e impatta
sull'opinione pubblica come abbiamo
visto nel caso delle vaccinazioni
ultimamente laddove ci sono stati due
approcci di comunicazione 1 vigliacco
che è quello che si mette dalla parte
dell'ac della cattedra e la scienza
diventa in qualche modo sacerdozio e a
quello che non dobbiamo fare perché c'è
sfiducia tanto che siamo dovuti passare
all'obbligo vaccinale tanto è stato
l'errore comunicativo e tornare invece
accadere un pochino quale la psicologia
dell'individuo che c'è dietro
e perché soprattutto c'è questa grande
abbondanza le informazioni false perché
siamo esseri umani siamo limitati e
abbiamo voglia di conoscere sete di
conoscenza sete di conoscenza che a
volte è indotta da placare l'ansia siamo
di fronte alla globalizzazione
globalizzazione è un mostro che non
riusciamo ad enti ficcare completamente
è un qualcosa che in qualche modo ci
riguarda ma non le capiamo bene i
confini in qualche modo si manifesta con
l'immigrazione col fatto che gli stati
non sono in grado di gestire i flussi
economici che si muovono su scala
sovranazionale e in ogni caso siamo
tutti figli della stessa scimmia
tendiamo a finire colmare quei buchi con
idee e narrazioni cerchiamo tutti una
narrazione che in qualche modo ci dia un
senso della nostra esistenza
poi c'è anche un altro problema è
l'interconnettività interconnettività
ovvero possiamo accedere ad una quantità
abnorme di informazioni senza precedente
e siamo tutti connessi non c'è più il
vincolo di prossimità e poi c'è il
processo
diciamo il progresso scientifico del
progresso scientifico che per conto suo
evolver evolve ad una velocità senza
precedenti
e in qualche modo ci spiazza modifica la
nostra percezione e la nostra società e
la nostra sfera cognitiva di
relazionamento quella quella realtà
e poi anche questa è stata utilizzata
come blasone un po come tecnico dal
giornalismo non soltanto uno strano ma
internazionale
l'analfabetismo funzionale ovvero
incapacità di capire quello che si legge
ma non è perché siamo scemi e
semplicemente perché siamo bombardati da
informazioni bombardati calcolate che
un'informazione a un periodo di durata
per la fruizione ricerca due minuti il
nostro cervello spanna tra gli otto ai
dodici secondi
tendiamo un'impressione collezioniamo
l'informazione mettiamo tutto insieme e
lo leghiamo ad uno strato emotivo e
quella diventa l'interpretazione è
quello che abbiamo cercato di fare noi
da un punto di vista scientifico è
quello di preparare un esperimento su
grandi moli di dati 1 su 2 milioni quasi
tre milioni di persone e un altro su 55
milioni di persone e poi ne abbiamo
fatto uno all'inizio di quest'anno su
376 milioni di persone per capire il
rapporto dell'essere umano con le
narrazioni che acquisisca acquisisce sui
social
in particolare abbiamo preso tutte le
fonti di informazione scientifiche e
tutte le fonti di informazione
alternative complottiste non l'abbiamo
preso ovviamente la parte di nessuno dei
due
perché la scienza evolve ed è fatto da
esseri umani e spesso e volentieri tira
fuori delle panzane mostruose dall'altra
l'informazione alternativa sporta
diciamo uno stato creativo ma in qualche
modo avendo fatto a iniziare tutte
quante queste pagine siamo andati a
vedere come gli utenti si relazionano
con queste diverse narrazioni la
narrazione scientifica e quella
alternativa viene fuori un risultato
abbastanza banale abbiamo rifatto i
conti per questo grafico almeno otto
volte li abbiamo mandati anche ai nostri
colleghi all'estero perché era troppo
regolare o seguiamo fonti di
informazione scientifica o seguiamo
fonti di informazione complottista in
mezzo non c'è nessuno ci sono
giornalisti anche direttori dei
telegiornali che ultima capire che in
mezzo a quelle due curve
ci sia una grande quantità di gente che
non si esprime non è vero pure il
giornalista ha bisogno del tecnico per
garantire il suo ruolo e che cosa
succede succede che siamo nel mondo in
cui il numero di like che mettiamo su
una specifica narrativa influenza il
numero di persone da cui siamo
circondati che fanno la stessa cosa
ovvero più sono attivo su una pagina più
tenderò è alta la probabilità che io sia
circondato nella mia sfera di amici su
facebook da persone che fanno
esattamente la stessa cosa se credo che
il vaccino non vada erogato sarò
circondato da persone che supportano la
mia visione del mondo è chiamata la
legge della polarizzazione dei gruppi
due persone che sono accomunate da una
tesi tenderà non essere più estreme e a
cercare conforto nel legame solidale
resiste tra loro questo crea quel
fenomeno che è stato in qualche modo
pompato sui media ormai è diventato po
di ordine pubblico
le eco chambers le casse di risonanza
ovvero siamo possiamo accedere ad un
mare magnum l'informazione troviamo
l'informazione che più ci aggrada
troviamo persone che sono simili a noi e
insieme a loro
costruiamo la narrazione ma come
reagiamo ad informazioni che sono
coerenti con la nostra visione del mondo
ma contengono informazioni palesemente
false messe per scherzo tipo se credo
nella narrazione alternativa e nella
cura naturale come reagirò ad
un'informazione fatta apposta che mi
dice che posso curare la congiuntivite
con il limone oppure che all'interno
delle scie chimiche ci sia il viagra
queste informazioni queste informazioni
vengono assorbite dalla comunità che
crede nella narrazione nell'ottanta per
cento dei casi
questo significa che un'informazione non
importa se sia coerente o meno o vera o
meno l'importante è che sostenga e
supporti la mia visione del mondo
la mia narrazione sia essa scientifica
sia essa complottiste alternativa e
questo è un risultato invece che diciamo
ha fatto
un impatto notevole nell'ambito globale
come rispondono alle persone ad
informazioni che sono a contrasto con la
loro visione del mondo per esempio vado
dal giornalista e gli dico che dare
l'informazione corretta non risolve il
problema delle fake news oppure vado da
qualcuno che crede nelle scie chimiche e
gli dico che le scie chimiche non
esistono come reagisce ignora
l'informazione non la guarda neanche a
quel punto ci siamo andati a prendere
quei pochi esposti di 10 milioni di
persone più o meno abbiamo 5.000
interazioni effettive quindi 5.000
utenti che hanno interagito di questi 5
mila utenti che hanno interagito con i
post di the banking come vengono
chiamati il risultato è di rinforzo
ovvero dopo l'esposizione al posto dei
the banking saranno attive nel consumare
informazione complottista cercheranno
conferme nel loro gruppo
l'impatto è stato quello di far chiudere
la colonna delle banche in gara dal
washington post ha nel 2015
siamo stati tradotti in quasi tutte le
lingue e siamo finiti su scientific
american
anche se in italia per l'abilitazione
scientifica nazionale ancora queste cose
non sono considerate scienza l'impatto e
ricerca di impatto samantha power
ambasciatore statunitense all'onu alla
creatura actions e rimini di gail parla
degli eco chamber dell'effetto e
identifica esattamente il problema la
soluzione non dobbiamo parlare con
qualcuno perché dobbiamo convincerlo
dobbiamo parlare con qualcuno perché
potrebbe aver ragione potrebbe anche
aver ragione ritornare e restaurare il
processo della comunicazione
a questo fine abbiamo aperto lanciato
l'iniziativa va all'università ca
foscari che ho avuto l'onore di
raggiungere da settembre quindi un mese
che son lì dove partiamo con pan doors
pandor greco inglese per dire tutte le
porte e anche una nomenclatura con il
vaso di pandora o pandoro a seconda di
come lo si vuol vedere
e l'idea è quella di creare sinergie tra
istituzioni testate giornalistiche
scienza su una base che sia quantitativa
che parta dall'umiltà e non dalla
speculazione che tendenzialmente tende a
creare più fec news che risposte sensate
a quello che succede per esempio per
quanto riguarda la questione marginale
perché non cerchiamo di capire quali
sono effettivamente le resistenze delle
persone all'anno alla vaccinazione
piuttosto che attaccarle e dare
dell'imbecille soltanto per corroborare
il nostro ego perché siamo diventati
molto narcisisti sui social
siamo diventati molto narcisisti e per
rompere il narcisismo
dobbiamo ritornare all'empatia imparare
a comunicare capire che siamo tutti
figli della stessa scimmia
grazie
[Applauso]